PROFESSOR: So so far
even though these things
look maybe interesting
or a little familiar,
we have not yet stated clearly
how they apply to physics.
We've been talking about vector
spaces, V, for a particle.
Then V tensor N. And we've
looked at states there.
We've looked at permutation
operators there.
Symmetric states there.
Antisymmetric states there.
What is missing is
something that connects
it to quantum mechanics.
And that is given by the
so-called symmetrization
postulate.
So it's a postulate.
It's something that you
technically can't derive.
Therefore, you postulate.
You can say it's an extra
axiom even, quantum mechanics.
You would say also
that probably there's
no other way to do things.
So in some sense, it's forced.
But I think it's more honest to
admit it's an extra postulate.
So here it goes.
I'll read it first.
Then I'll write it.
So it says the following.
If you have a system of
N identical particles,
arbitrary states in V tensor
N are not physical states.
The physical states
are the states
that are totally symmetric.
In that case, the particles
are called bosons.
Or totally antisymmetric,
in which case
the particles are
called fermions.
That's basically it.
The arbitrary state that
is neither symmetric
nor antisymmetric,
and all that is not
a physical state of a system
of identical particles.
So it's stated here.
In a system with N
identical particles,
physical states are not
arbitrary states in V tensor N.
Rather, they are
totally symmetric.
In parentheses, they
belong to SymN of V.
In which case, the particles
are said to be bosons
or they are totally
antisymmetric.
Are totally antisymmetric.
They belong to anti NV.
In which case, they are
said to be fermions.
All right.
So this is really
pretty fundamental.
It's a statement that
we began our discussion
by saying we have an
electron at this up
and another electron
at this down.
Is it the plus minus state or
is it the minus plus state?
And we said it's neither one.
You cannot declare those
two to be equivalent.
And that's what this says.
It's not arbitrary
states in this.
But they have to become
totally symmetric,
if they're bosons or
totally antisymmetric
if they are fermions.
So we have to make
a few comments.
And that's what will keep
us busy for the next 20,
25 minutes.
And to understand this
and see what it implies
and how we use it.
So here it is.
The statement we have
made is a statement
of fact in three dimensions.
There's no particles that
we like and we study.
There are further
possibilities in worlds
of lower dimension two, three
dimensions, space, time,
or so two dimensional
space, that
allows for further
kinds of statistics
that are interesting.
But this is the
general statement.
So the first comment is this
is the general statement.
But further statistics,
other types of space,
exist in two dimensions,
not in three, where we live.
We say three in
the Galilean ways.
3 plus 1 time.
But this is spatial dimensions.
This is the
statistical definition
of bosons and fermions.
But then comes the spin
statistics theorem.
That applies then you understand
with quantum mechanics.
And that's a deep
theorem that ends up
telling you that
particles with spin 0, 1,
2 integer are bosons.
And particles with spin 1/2,
3/2 [INAUDIBLE] are fermions.
So it's a great achievement
of quantum field
theory associating the
statistical properties
with the spin.
It's a deep connection.
It's valid for
elementary particles
or composite particles.
The list of particles
is not that big.
Particles of spin 1,
we know a lot of them.
A photon is spin 1.
Gluons are spin 1.
The w's, the c's are
spin 1 particles.
Particles spin 0.
We didn't know an
elementary one for a while.
We finally know the
[INAUDIBLE] is there, spin 0.
Particles of spin 2.
Just [INAUDIBLE] along.
Higher spin unknown.
It may exist.
String theory has them.
All kinds of theories
postulate them.
They may exist.
They may not.
Spin of 1/2, fractional spin.
Well, all the matter particles,
quarks, muons, leptons,
neutrinos are spin 1/2.
Spin 3/2 is hypothetical
as an elementary particle.
If it exists, it would
be called the gravitino.
There are composite particles.
You could [INAUDIBLE]
with quarks,
or with other particles,
mesons, baryons.
You can get several spins.
Not with elementary particles.
Many time unstable particles.
So anyway, those are
very interesting things.
Now next fact is that you can
go from elementary particles
to composite particles.
So if you have, for
example, the hydrogen atom.
That this has a proton
and an electron.
And you want to figure out
if it's a boson or a fermion.
Well, you think of another
hydrogen atom here, p and e.
And you write a
wave function that
involves the protons, the first
proton, the second proton,
the first electron, and
the second electron.
That's a little bit
of a funny notation.
This would correspond
to maybe the coordinates
of the first proton, the second
proton, the first electron,
the second electron.
Since protons are identical
particles that are fermions,
the wave function
must change sign
if P1 and P2 are exchanged.
There would be a minus sign.
It's antisymmetric.
Since the electrons
are fermions,
it should antisymmetric
by exchanging this 2.
So it's also antisymmetric
under this exchange.
So finally, if you exchange
this item with this item,
you must exchange the two
protons and the two electrons
at the same time.
Two minuses and you get a plus.
Therefore, the hydrogen
atom is a boson.
So these statistical
properties build up.
So an object built
with a number of bosons
and a number of fermions
will be a boson or a fermion,
depending on those numbers.
So that's a nice thing.
So the hydrogen atom is a boson.